depuis 2014 le tiers des résidences
privées pour aînés ont dû fermer leurs
portes et la lourdeur de la bureaucratie
n'y est pas étrangère résidence
outremont jim dine shelly pas si
maintenant plus tard remplir des
formulaires et à se conformer à de
nouveaux règlements que s'occuper de ses
résidents s'est rendu en ce moment une
bureaucratie tellement lourde que je
suis rendu je rempli des papiers des
papiers des papiers je ne me suis jamais
peut occuper de ma clientèle ont fait
rajouter des têtes de gicleurs à
déclenchement rapide donc faire ajouter
plus de luminosité ont fait rajouter des
détecteurs de fumée et des détecteurs de
chaleur on peut pas appliquer les mêmes
normes dans une petite résidence comme
par exemple la mienne ou personnes
cuisine personne fume dans les
appartements
l'incendié d'une résidence pour aînés à
l'île verte en 2014 et il déclencheur
d'une série de règlements bien
intentionné mais qui coûte cher il ya eu
un resserrement de la réglementation
pour augmenter la sécurité des résidents
mais cette augmentation la apporte des
cours importants pour les résidences ces
petites résidences le nom ne peuvent pas
augmenter les loyers puisque les
résidents auront une capacité de payer
limité alors ses dépenses à coups de
10000 de 15000 s'entraîne des des
problèmes et des grosses grosses
difficultés financières
les règles de sécurité ça on peut pas
jouer avec ça mais par contre on peut
très bien trouver une voie de passage
pour être en mesure d'accompagner les
propriétaires de ces petites résidences
afin qu ils puissent garder leurs portes
ouvertes et et s'occuper des aînés le
cake s'est engagé à favoriser le
maintien à domicile et y construire des
maisons pour aînés à échelle humaine
raison de 35 par année encore faut-il
trouver l'argent et le personnel c'est
un très grande préoccupation je
comprends la détresse des personnes
aînées et de leurs familles avec un
nombre restreint de résidence de plus en
plus d'aînés vont devoir être des restes
de leur milieu pour aller finir leurs
jours loin de l'endroit où ils ont
toujours vécu ici michel marsolais radio
canada montréal